now there are a lot of euphemisms we
hear women is considered politically
incorrect because it has the word man in
it
so some women like to the feminist types
want to spell it w-i-m-m-i-n
you've heard of the idea of uh woe
person
but of course son is still very sexist
and politically incorrect
so you'd really have to rename it
whopper daughter
there are other terms that have come up
the new one this
this might be the strangest of all from
healthline magazine
calls women vulva owners
do the headline here is do vulva owners
like sex is the wrong question here is
what you should ask
instead this is written by a i guess a
vulva owner herself jennifer
littner who writes what's the short
answer it depends on the person
some like sex and some don't just like
some
owners of male genitalia like sex and
some don't okay
i i i'm not gonna get into this is this
is a family show so i'm not gonna
get into all of this when i first saw
the headline i thought it said do do
volvo owners like sex
which is that's a euphemism for the
upper middle class and i thought i think
they do i'm pretty sure they do
volvo owners tend to have kids but in
any case the the phrase they're using is
vulva
owners so if you own a
women's genitalia then you you like sex
something that's very revealing about
this new euphemism though
is not just that it misunderstands women
i mean truly how objectifying is it
you are you are in that case treating
women
as only material they don't have a
spiritual component they don't have a
soul
they're just their flesh and then you
are objectifying women by saying that
you own
them you own this piece of them but it
also misunderstands humanity
because i guess you if you wanted to be
politically correct couldn't you say
persons with vulvas or something you
know just
you've heard this kind of language used
especially by the transgender movement
but now they're saying
owner and it reveals uh two things that
are really wrong
one that people are just viewing
themselves as meat puppets
you know as we're just we can just be
boiled down to our flesh
but also that we own ourselves that
that we we possess ourselves
in a way that we would possess a leftist
tears tumbler or we would
possess note cards or we would possess a
microphone it's a
a point of view a vision of the human
person
from the from a consumerist or
materialist perspective and it's really
really wrong
uh liberals and even some i guess some
libertarians tend to
have this idea that we own our bodies
and we can do whatever we want with our
bodies and
we can do whatever we want there's no
moral order that we have to answer to
and we have no responsibility
to use our liberty toward justice we
that that idea is kind of gone
in the liberal and even libertarian
vision of things
the conservative view is very different
though in the conservative view
i don't own my body i don't have the
right to do whatever i want at all times
as long as i don't
scare the horses in the street or hurt
somebody i have a
responsibility to the moral order i have
i have responsibilities to my
fellow citizens i have responsibilities
to my family i have responsibilities to
my country
and so i'm not just free to do whatever
i want with my body which is why you
rarely see conservatives
mutilating themselves or or
disrespecting their bodies
and when they do disrespect their bodies
they feel shame for it
that's i mean this is a very stupid
headline and people should make fun of
the article but it actually does reveal
a big difference in the way that the
left and the right
view themselves and view
society
[Music]
[Music]